we can hello uh somebody wants it we'll
figure way to guess what Lux Imogen was
messing with your demands
no that's what Reagan did Reagan that's
oh and that's what we've done ever since
then and what do we call it insanity
right doing the same [ __ ] over and over
again with expecting a different result
so we spend millions and every year we
lose 70,000 Americans to drug overdose
and in reality that numbers by 140,000 I
just saw our study by John Hopkins where
it says we're talking about direct but
we're not talking about people that die
driving under the influence of drugs
we're not talking about many other
deaths that are caused because of drug
suicide addiction yeah exactly suicides
but nobody does that right you know when
we worry about it when someone in our
house dies god forbid or someone close
to us then we're all worried about him
we want to do something about drug
addiction right but in the meantime why
you know who's talking about it
nobody's talking about it well now this
year 140,000 will die
twice as much right because big pharma
Dean so I go out to Big Pharma and I
said to Big Pharma said look drugs don't
kill people you're not killing people
people killing themselves the drugs you
make and the money that you make
you got a more responsibility to help
and invest in those communities I call
it the LeBron James motto you know what
LeBron I'm not a family run James
why basketball he's a great athlete I'm
a big fan of hammers a human being well
he left Miami I was on Miami Heat fans
that why I like him no I do like him I
love you but LeBron James has done is
what every every african-american leader
and every personal color Latino needs to
do you created that school he put all
the money on his pocket right those kids
are out scoring every other kid in Akron
Ohio and he's teaching the kids and
teaching the parents if you don't magic
eight your community listen we can burn
America to the Pope we ain't gonna stop
people from hating people
we got does his biblical ties man you
think LeBron James should run for
president one day
no but I think no I can't
you can't I got all my rights back what
I mean this was 40 years ago down
remember okay so 79 was my conviction
you pull some strings so no no wow I
can't own a gun though you know right I
still cannot own a firearm so that's one
thing but
that's why our do you watch basketball
are you yeah yeah do you think they
should start it back up yeah they should
yeah of course but now he's hold money
right right all about money it's all
about the owners make all the money at
all people are gonna lose their jobs if
they don't start it back up yeah because
we think of all those rich basketball
players we think about the LeBron James
and the Curia Rizzo but it's a lot of
them not a living day today right
exactly
okay yeah so you know so we got we got
that problem so we gotta invest in the
community and this is what I tell the
people so look it's wonderful you got
Michael Jordan donate a hundred million
now I'm like eight dude what were you
when Kaepernick was freaking what were
you guys protesting when this guy was
was his career devastated you know are
we doing this now because because now is
its expedient or is because it's about
time but let's be real I'm a person of
color I if I think for a minute that
every person and he talked about prism
there's just as much producing not have
people of color had a worse chance have
african-americans in America have
suffered a lot yeah they have there's no
doubt about that
but no matter what we do we never change
people's perspective if people hate you
they're gonna hate you no matter what no
matter if you are what but what we can
change is they can respect us and unless
we start with another thing criminal
justice reform now there's where you got
the big there's where the root of the
all the problem success if I was leading
all that money that's been giving I said
this is what we're gonna do we're gonna
go out to this politician we're gonna
stop that crap because when they passed
the 1986 Act that passed and all of a
sudden you get five years for 10 grams
of crack but you need a thousand grams
of powder it's 100 to 1 whatever that
number is 100 to 1 I'm like then we
figure this [ __ ] out that who deals with
crack people of color Latinos and blacks
who deals with powder white Americans
right so why won't we why haven't we
been protesting this way knows and we
realized that they are locking up our
kids that are not criminal giving him a
life sentence because
the prison system is a money-making
enterprise for special interest groups
they don't look at it mates like people
their inventory so unless you a man like
Van Jones is done with the cars I listen
elected officials are that elected they
don't walk up to Washington say hey I'm
here
I'm your leader I'm your Congressman we
put their ass in there well you know how
we changed America we get them people
their sorry ass out of them we pass laws
that are just and we and we force
rehabilitation instead of punishment you
know and in the crime the punishment
must fit the crime and then if we do
that and we help those kids to get out
together to be rehabilitated to learn a
trade in prison instead of just
warehousing them in overcrowded prison
so that it becomes very tumultuous right
then you know what those kids will go
back to the communities and they'll
change other kids unless we change our
communities unless I look at my my
latest grandbaby right born in January
fat gorgeous and my wife and I set up a
college fund for all of our grandkids I
said that kid's gonna have every chance
in life to succeed but this a little
african-american kid born in a community
in America with a father in jail a
mother that might be on drugs or a
prostitute crying in that crib with no
one changing his diaper and who's gonna
raise him the gangs are gonna raise him
and what is that kid gonna end up the
kids gonna end up in prison and then it
becomes a vicious cycle and if the
father goes to prison
80% chance the kid goes to prison right
so because the vicious cycle so unless
we attack all those different fronts and
then we educate our children because a
lot of them cannot even go to school
because they gotta eat they don't have
any money so governor you wanna do
something pay those kids money to get a
trade electrician and a plumber makes 85
bucks an hour
80% of all middle middle management
don't make that in America so help them
believe me if you invest in a young
person and if you show them why think
about this why does a young kid at the
age of 12 kill someone get in a circle
take an humble
beating almost to death to join a gang
so someone can tell him 24 hours a day
what the hell to do why because he's
looking for meaning and belonging and
someone that loves them and that's what
the gang does and then we complain right
but we don't care you know so we have
this horrific death by a demon because
if you look at the guy's eyes man to me
was like he was demonic yeah I mean he's
been filmed freaking film yeah there's
nothing there there's nothing he's just
looking at like I don't give a [ __ ] if
I'm gonna die in prison I killed this
this piece of whatever in his eyes right
not a human being not a son you know not
a brother nothin didn't give a damn
about nothing
so yeah they should they shouldn't kill
I got any to put him in a jail for the
rest of his life because that's if you
tell me died in prison or or Sparky they
like the chair say take me to Sparky
buddy he yeah cuz prison and for a guy
like that ain't gonna make it anyway so
but that's that's how I look it was the
big difference between the palete local
police and other types of military I
mean and even higher up levels like the
FBI and the CIA or even a Navy SEALs
there's a huge difference in the amount
of training and education and education
you have to have a college degree to be
a DEA or FBI you don't to be a cop right
so that should be something mandatory
and they and they in there and this
should be more money invested in weeding
out everybody knows listen that ain't
the first complaint the guys had so why
don't you have six and he's still doing
this crap yeah I think the basic
underwater demolition SEALs training
there's hundreds of people that get
flushed out of that course every single
day when they go through training sure
it's basically not only is it physical
endurance but it's it's your character
and your mental endurance to be able to
get through that kind of torture only
the people that can make it through that
are the people are gonna have the type
of character that it takes to go to
another country and deal with a
completely foreign community and try to
weed out the bad people and I mean
there's so many different very variables
to it yeah it's so easy to become a cop
anybody can become a cop exact hours of
training a year I think you have to go
through it's no it's horrible and that
needs to be fleshed out and that needs
to be cleaned up but you know at the end
of the day again I go back to the same
thing when I came for me I was 10 years
old I see the woman you
with a big billboard no animal no Cubans
and go back to you and then I go to
school and I see the girls laugh at me
and say hey George are you going to a
party Saturday oh I didn't know about it
and then she's uh ha ha we don't invite
people like you go back go back to where
you came from and on and on and yeah and
I've been with my mom on the phone when
I've had somebody said to me speak
English you're in America I said dude I
don't know if you know this but we spoke
Spanish it's 200 years before you guys
came but the thing about it is you got
to come to grips with the fact that we
call it racism prejudice is gonna exist
forever
it's never gonna stop I don't care what
anybody says my job was not to make
those people like me right my job was to
better myself become somebody make them
respect me right and that's I come out
of prison twice convicted drug dealer he
fighting reinvent myself
he fighting at a school and get a PhD I
recall it twice convicted drug dealer
instead of doctor right so we got to
educate our kids that's that's basic
because an uneducated nation is a
controllable nation right and then if
they don't have no education people that
survive it's survival to finish I tell
you when I come out of prison
if no one will give me a job because I
have a big billboard says twice
convicted drug dealer don't hire me and
I couldn't feed my family kids you know
what I was gonna do I wasn't gonna worry
about it I was gonna go back to my I
mean smuggle drugs again
I know how to do that why cuz I got to
eat and have my life not changed yeah
had I not given my life to Christ yeah I
had I not mentally sane but I gotta eat
and when you gotta eat in with us
survive you will do whatever it takes
right that's human nature
[Music]
[Laughter]